hey it's evan today i wanted to share
an app that i'm using for my son and
what i love about the app is not just
the app itself but the marketing that
they do
is genius and it's something that
anybody can can leverage and
model for their own business first of
all the app is called zoodles it's
actually kids app
and for those of you have kids you
should definitely check it out you're
gonna love it
basically what it does is it's a free
app to start with and
it'll lock your phone so that when your
child is using your phone
they can't get into any programs that
you haven't approved for them so they
can get into whatever you set up that
they can see
otherwise they can't get into your email
or change your settings or send clients
strange pictures they can't do any of
that a lot of times you get your phone
back from your kid and everything's been
changed around
so i have a four-year-old son and the
only way that he can get access to
the programs that are not set up by me
is for him to enter in my birth year
which he doesn't know
so it's a great program the next thing
you can do is
you enter in a picture of your child and
their age
and what it will do is automatically
bring in programs and learning tools
that are appropriate for them
so my son is four he'll see programs
that relate to accounting and math and
early science skills and grammar skills
and
kind of learning the alphabet that kind
of stuff they'll show it for him and if
your
child is seven or ten or two you'll see
related programs so i thought that alone
was pretty genius
that alone was worth getting the program
for
the genius thing they do on on the
marketing side though is i get a
update i don't let my son use my phone
that much i try to limit his screen time
but when he does i try to he uses this
program
and they sent me an update so this is
something that zoodles will send me
as an example and it sends me what he
drew
so this is what my son drew on the phone
again he's four years old
so i can click on that and print that
off and i guess if your child is older
and producing something
something nicer you can send it off to
your family too but it's nice that it
sends me an email
with all the updates i didn't know he
was doing any of this stuff
it tells me where he's spending his time
so again as you can see i don't let him
use the phone that much but
cognitive development life skills math
you can see how it's broken down
if he's watching videos or playing games
and so it's really cool to see
you know the apps he's using characters
that are involved in
in the programs he's learning about he's
learned about responsibility accounting
and citizenship and all this stuff
it's great to see this report of what he
likes how he's using it what he's
learning
because i'm not following along all the
time when he's on the phone
it's really cool to get this update so
if you're you know whatever program you
have you want to make sure you're
providing detailed usage of how people
are
are going and using and benefiting from
your product
because this is mind-blowing this is
mind-blowing how much
they tell me about what my son is doing
with the program the thing that started
to get me to buy with this email before
so this came to my email my son loves
baseball i love baseball
hayden requested a book so this is my
son hayden and
on one of the zoodle programs are books
and you can either buy a book
individually you can buy the
the premium package or the thing is five
bucks a month or something
and what it does is allow you to read a
book and record a video of yourself
reading the book
to your child and i thought it was
amazing that he clicked on the book
and i guess a message popped up to say
that he couldn't read the book but it
triggers an email to me the parent to
say
your son is interested in this book and
i thought it was it was interesting at
the start i said hayden did you request
this book he's like yeah yeah i clicked
on that link
i clicked on the book i clicked on the
book and it's just amazing how they do
the marketing
afterwards to hook the parents in on
wanting to
upgrade and start paying for the product
so even as a free tool it's a great if
your parent is a great tool to get into
provide some learning tools for your
kids so not just playing angry birds on
the phone all day
but i found the interaction
amazing of how they managed to get me to
quickly
upgrade and give me detailed stats on
what my son is doing that makes me want
to stay with the program and maybe even
buy
more and more and more so if you are in
the app business or you're marketing any
kind of product
i would try as much as possible to show
these kind of detailed reports to hook
people
get them interested in your product show
how people are using it especially if
it's not
them using it it's their people on their
team who are using it or people in their
family that are using it you can show
their usage of what they're doing
i just thought it was a great way to
market it and i wanted to share with you
guys so if you guys like this video let
me know
leave a thumbs up below if you have a
comment about zoodle specifically
or another app or you have a question
for your business leave it in the
comment section below
i'll make a video response thank you so
much and i'll see you soon